i i remember as a kid um
looking up to space and and just
marveling at
uh at the moon landing and imagining
people
on the moon and i think ever since then
kids have been looking
back now hopefully with this new era of
space travel kids can start looking
uh looking forward uh with hope that
they can they
with hope that they too can uh go into
space one day
and we're going to do everything we can
to make it possible um you know we've
we've launched this this prize um
uh to try to get to two people who could
never dream of going to space to go to
space and hopefully
that will generate a whole lot more uh
tickets for
people to go into space and uh and let
them
let the people watching this program
maybe have an opportunity one day to go
to space
you said it so many times it's not a
race and you've had congratulations from
some of those rivals you have but what
do you think
the fact that it's been done means now
for this business of space tourism that
it's been achieved
that now we're in a different era as you
said well it
i think it means that our space
factories need to
get to work in building a lot of
spaceships i mean we've
created something that is completely
unique um
you know obviously virgin galactic
thinks what we've done is more unique
than
our rivals and i'm sure they'll argue
the other way but it is completely
unique
um and and now i've experienced it i
know that every
everybody uh uh everybody out there i
think
um by my wife maybe i would love would
love would love to go to space
did you ever doubt really that it would
happen this moment would happen it's
been 17 years
um uh did i ever doubt it would happen
i i'm sure if i'm honest with myself
there were moments where
uh you know tough moments but we you
know this wonderful group of engineers
has stuck with it
um and uh and i just
could not be happier that we we finally
achieved this dream i just
you know obviously we've got we're gonna
have to let people have been waiting
for patiently for 17 years who bought
tickets to go
one day if we're lucky and we've got
enough spaceships and there's an
empty seat we might be able to catch
along again and it would be fabulous